اهلا بكم اقتحمت قوه مسلحه مقر المؤتمر
الوطني الليبي في العاصمه طرابلس وسيطرت
على محيطه لمده وجيزه قبل ان تنسحب منه
ياتي هذا بعد ساعات من تاكيد اللواء
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر في بنغازي ان قواته
ستواصل عملياتها دفاعا عن الشعب وارواح
جنود القوات المسلحه الليبيه الذين يتم
اغتيالهم نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما مدى ثقه لقوات اللواء حفتر
وتاثيرها في الواقع الليبي المضطرب امنيا
وسياسيا ما هي خيارات السلطات الليبيه في
طرابلس للتعامل مع هذه الازمه واحتواء
تداعياتها
[موسيقى]
من جديد وبعد محاولته الانقلابيه في
فبراير شباط الماضي يدخل اللواء المتقاعد
في الجيش الليبي خليفه حفتر هو وقواته
بؤره الاحداث فقد اعلن متحدث باسمه
مسؤوليه قوه تابعه له عن اقتحام مقر
المؤتمر الوطني العام في العاصمه طرابلس
وذلك قبل ان تستعيد السيطره على المقر
كتائب الثوار وقد نفى حفتر ان تكون تحركات
القوات المواليه له في بنغاز
ان تكون انقلابا او سعيا للسلطه متهما
اطرافا في السلطات الليبيه بالتواطؤ مع ما
دعاه الارهاب مؤكدا ان قواته ستواصل
معركتها ضد هذا الارهاب حتى تحقيق كامل
اهدافها من بنغازي الى طرابلس تنتقل
الاحداث وتتسارع قوات مسلحه تابعه للواء
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر تقتحم مقر المؤتمر
الوطني العام تدهم مكاتب اعضاء البرلمان
وتضرم اليران في المبنى قبل ان تنسحب من
محيط المكان بعيد ذلك تدور اشتباكات في
منطقه بوسليم في العاصمه حدث هذا عقب
تقديم رئيس الوزراء المكلف تشكيله حكومته
للبرلمان الذي سارع الى رفع جلسته واخلى
مقره لوصول معلومات لاعضائه باقتحام وشيك
للمقر حفتر يقود اذا هجوما منسقا على
طرابلس وبنغازي معا ولا يعتبر ذلك انقلابا
اضطر الطلائع احرار الجيش الوطني الليبي
الى خوضها دفاعا عن الوطن والشعب وعن حياه
وارواح ضباطنا وجنود القوات المسلحه الذين
تم ويتم اغتيالهم
بالمئات وليست انقلابا ولا سعيا الى
السلطه حربه اذا على الارهاب كما يقول
الرجل ويؤكد لقد قصف ف جوا مواقع قال انها
تابعه لمجموعات ارهابيه في بنغازي واشتبك
مسلحون مناصرون له مع هؤلاء وانطلقت
الطائره المهاجمه من مطار بنينا المجاور
اكثر من ذلك يقول مناصر الرجل انه لديه
قاعده ولاء وتاييد في صفوف بعض جنرالات
الجيش من متقاعدين ومن ساسه طالهم قانون
العزل السياسي ويزيد من تعقيد المشهد غياب
جيش قوي في البلاد وعجز الحكومه في طرابلس
عن استكمال بناء مؤسسات الدوله ما جعل
كثيرا من الليبيين يخيرون الحكومه بين فرض
الامن والاستقرار او الرحيل ماذا تملك
الحكومه والبرلمان من خيارات امام هجمات
حفتر وتعالي الاصوات المندده بما تسميه
عجز المؤسسات عن معالجه الفوضه الامنيه في
البلاد نخب طرابلس تتحدث عن رد سيكون على
حفتر وبادوات نفسها وفي المدينه نفسها
التي شهدت استعراضه للقوه في بنغازي لكن
ضربه الرجل الاخيره في قلب العاصمه كانت
ردا استباقيا يتجاوز التهديد الى التنفيذ
وباسلوب حرب العصابات القائم على الكر
والفر يستنزف ويشغل ويبعث الرسائل لليبيين
بان البديل موجود وفي متناول
اليد ومعنا في هذه الحلقه من طرابلس منصور
الحصادي عضو المؤتمر الوطني العام الليبي
ومن بنغازي الدكتور ابو بكر بعيره استاذ
علم الاداره في جماعه بنغازي اهلا بضيفي
لو بدانا بطرابلس والسيد منصور
الحصادي برايكم ما الثقل الذي يشكله
اللواء حفتر والقوات التي تقف معه
الان نعم بدايه بسم الله الرحمن رحم
الرحيم في البدايه اتقدم باحر التعازي الى
كل اهالي واسر الذين سقطوا في اليومين
الماضيين كما اود من خلال قناه الجزيره
ومن خلال هذا البرنامج ان اتوجه الى الشعب
الليبي جميعا بالتهدئة
ومؤسساتها والمؤسسات ضعيفه لم نرث من
النظام السابق مؤسسات فعليه حقيقيه ولكن
نحن في طور البناء وفي طور التاسيس نعم
هذه من حيث البدايه من حيث البدايه ايضا
كان سؤالي عن الثقل الذي يمثله اللواء
حفتر نعم حقيقه السيد اللواء حفتر حقيقه
هو مهوس بشيء اسمى السلطه واسم اسما
العظمه هو على ارض الواقع ليس لديه ثقل هو
يحاول ان يستغل الفراغ الامني الموجود في
مدينه بني غازي يحاول استغلال عمليات
الاغتيال والقتل التي تحدث في مدينه
بنغازي وتحدث في مدينه درناه وتحدث في
مدينه العجيلات ونحن قلناها في المؤتمر
الوطني ونقولها بكل وضوح باننا ضد القتل
وضد الاعتداء وضد السطو من اي جهه كانت
وتحت اي مبرر كل من يقوم بقتل الليبيين هو
مجرم هو ارهابي لابد ان يقدم الى العداله
وستنال ايدي العداله في يوم من الايام هذا
من حيث المبدا اما على ارض الواقع فالسيد
حفتر ليس لديه قوه يحاول ان يعمل على
المتناقضات وانا استغرب من السيد حفتر انه
يقول اريد تامين مدينه بني غازي واريد
الثار لمن نقتي في مدينه بني غازي ثم ينقل
المعركه الى مدينه طرابلس ومدينه طرابلس
لا يوجد بها اغتيالات او عمليات قتل هي
محاوله انقلابيه بائسه على الشرعيه وعلى
ليبيا الجديده وعلى ثوره 17 فبراير
نعم بعد اذنك فقط بعد اذنك فقط لانك اشرت
الى ان السيد حفتر هو مهوس بالسلطه وليس
لديه قوه ولكن وهنا اسال
السيد الدكتور ابو بكر بعيره عن ما يراه
من ثقل هذا الرجل لان على الاقل هناك على
ما يبدو قطاعات تنظر الى ما يقوم به على
انه عمليه انقاذ من حاله فوضه تعيشها
ليبيا دكتور بعيره تفضل
نعم نعم احييك سيدان واحيي ضيوفك الكرام
وال المشاهدين اهلا بك اي الوضع في بنغازي
كما يعبر عنه الجميع وما يعرفه والجميع هو
وضع
ماساوي وتعيش بنغازي فراغا امنيا كبيرا
ومزعجا
ا اليوم قرات احدى الصحف في بنغازي واثارت
سؤال كبير مهم جدا اثارت سؤال من يوقف
الموت اليومي في
بنغازي اذا لو لم ياتي السيد حفتر لاتى
غيره المشكله قائمه وتحتاج الى علاج
وموت يوم
والخطف وال المصائب الاخرى
فاذا ما قام به السيد حفتر هو صرخه الواجب
للرد على هذه المشكلات لايقاف مسلسل القتل
في بنغازي نحن لا ندخل في قلب الرجل لا
نستطيع ان نتهم بان هو مغامر من اجل
السلطه كما يقول البعض الرجل له تاريخه
العسكري المعروف انا شخصيا لم التقي به
ولا اعرفه ولكنه قام بما يجب ان يقوم به
احد ما لايقاف هذا المسلسل الدامي في
مدينه بنغازي نعم لكن دكتور بعيره ما هي
قوته الحقيقيه لان البعض يريد حصره في
بنغازي ولكن اتضح ان لديه قوه ايضا في
طرابلس وحتى المتحدث باسم ما يسمى بالجيش
الوطني الليبي يقول لدينا غرف عمليات في
كثير من المدن الليبيه اذا ما هي قوته
الحقيقيه
ا لا استطيع ان اعطيك اجابه على هذا
السؤال انا لست عسكريا وكما ذكرت لك لا
اعرف السيد حفتر شخصيا ولكن على كلك حال
ما قام به يدل يدل على ان له قاعده يستند
اليها والتصريحات التي صدرت في مناطق
الشرق الليبي بالتحديد واليوم صدرت في
الغرب الليبي عن طريق ما تم ضد مقر
المؤتمر الوطني هذه كلها تشير الى ان هناك
من يساند السيد حفتر في موقفه ولكن اهم ما
من يقف مع السيد حفتر في هذا الموقف هو
الفراغ الامني الذي يستدعي ان يتدخل شخص
ما نعم على ذكر الفراغ الامني سيد منص صور
الحصدي ايه واضح ان السيد حفتر يركز على
امرين ان هناك فراغ امني وهناك فوضه وهناك
مليشيات تعبث كما تريد على الاقل هذا ما
يراه ومن الناحيه اخرى هناك سلطه تجاوزت
الاجال التي تعطيها شرعيه وبالتالي اصبحت
في وضع غير شرعي مثل هذا الخطاب
ايه هل تعتقد بانه قادر على جلب الليبيين
بغض النظر عن التحفظات التي اشرت اليها
قبل
قليل نعم هي يعني محاوله تظليل للراي
العام في
الحقيقه كون هناك بعض الميليشيات خارقه او
خارجه عن القانون توجد في كل مكان توجد في
بني غازي وتوجد في طرابلس وتوجد في الجنوب
وهذا شيء معروف ولكن من لديه رؤيه اصلاحيه
او مشروع اصلاحي سواء كان عسكري او سياسي
لابد ان يدخل من الباب الحقيقي و وان يدخل
من القنوات الحقيقيه الرئيسيه انا اقول
للسيد ابو بكر وهو استاذ اكاديمي باحث
معرو اسمحلي اسمح لي قبل ان تقول اسمح لي
قبل ان ت تقول للدكتور بعيره هذه الرؤيه
الاصلاحيه التي تشير اليها يفترض ان تقوم
بها السلطه ولكن السلطه لم تقم بدورها
فخلقت انطباع بان على غيرها ان يتحرك
نعم نعم نحن نقولها بكل صراحه ووضوح ان
الحكومه التنفيذيه كانت متمثله في السيد
علي زيدان كانت لديها ضعف كبير جدا في
تامين مدينه بنغازي وفي تامين مدينه درن
وفي تامين الجنوب وهذه حقيقه نحترف بها
وهذا هو السبب الذي جعل المؤتمر يسحب
الثقه من علي زيدان ونحن في جلسه اليوم
الثلاثاء القادم باذن الله سنصوت او نمنح
الثقه لحكومه السيد احمد ميتيك وانا اقول
ان المظاهره او الاقتحام اليوم هو من من
اهدافه هو عرقله حكومه السيد احمد عتيج من
ان تتولى الحكومه وتمارس مهامها ومن بين
مهامها الملف الامني المعقد في ليبيا التي
يحتاج الى وقفه منا جميعا نحن نحترف ان
هناك خروقات امنيه ولكن من يريد ان يساهم
في اصلاح ليبيا ومن لديه رؤيه سياسيه او
رؤيه عسكريه او رؤيه اقتصاديه ان يقدمها
من ابوابها الصحيحه وان ياتي البيوت من
ابوابها لا ان ياتي من الخلف ويحاول ان
يظلل الراي العام لو سمحت لي سيد انا احب
ان اذكر كره الليبيه بشيء مهم جدا في ال
69 لما قام القذافي بانقلابه المشؤوم حاول
ان يظلل الراي العام القذافي ومن معه
واذكر ان اللواء حفتر كان مع القذافي
انقلب على الملك ادريس هذا الرجل الصالح
هذا الملك المعروف على مملكه دستوريه هتف
له الكثير من الشعب الليبي نتيجه التظليل
الاعلامي اللي كان موجود في تلك الفتره
ونحن في ليبيا لا نريد ان نقع وان نكرر
نفس الخطر نحن نؤكد على
ثوابت اسمحي سيد
حصدي اشرت اكثر من مره الى كلمه تضليل
ولكن هناك مساله اريد ان انقلها للدكتور
بعيره هناك مساله مهمه لم تشر اليها سيد
حصادي هو
ان واضح ان سيد
حفتر يعني قادر على اثاره نقاط الراي
العام الليبي ايضا مشغول بها يعني عندما
يتحدث عن جماعات تكفيريه او جماعات
ارهابيه او فوضى سلاح او غيره سيد ابو بكر
بع هل
تعتقد لا اسمحلي حتى نكون متوازنين حتى
نكون متوازنين قل سيد بعيره هل تعتقد بان
هذا هذا الخطاب قادر على سيد بعيره هل
تعتقد ان هذا الخطاب قادر
على جمع الناس حول السيد
حفتر نعم اعتقد ان اللواء
حفتر ذهب مباشره القضيه التي تشغل بال
الليبيين بنغازي تعيش حاله من الفوضى التي
لا استطيع ان اصفها لك قتل في الشوارع
اي على رؤوس الاشهاد خطف مختلف الجرائم
ولا احد يتحرك الدوله في طرابلس ناسيه
منطقه اسمها بنغازي ولا تهتم بها على
الاطلاق ولذلك يعني
يفترض او كان متوقع ان يقوم احد ما بهذا
العمل انا اعتقد ان السيد حفتر لدي قدر
كبير من الجراه لا
شك دكتور دكتور لماذا لماذا لم ينسق هذا
التحرك مع السلطه المركزيه حتى وان كان
لديه تحفظات حول شرعيتها الان لان تحركه
الان يبتو وكان بامكان اي شخص انذ القانون
كما
يريده استاذ محمد السلطه المركزيه لا
تستجيب لاحد احنا هذه مشكلتنا مع السلطه
المركزيه كما يقولون وذن من طين وذن من
عجين سواء المؤتمر او الحكومه لا تستمع
الى احد واحنا هذه مشكلتنا معها نعينه
فيها من خلال سنوات وسنوات وسنوات لا
تستجيب لاحد ولا تستمع الى احد وكانها
نازله من فوق من السماء والناس عايشه
غارقه في المشاكل فلا بد من وجود حلول
عمليه واعتقد احد هذه الحلول العمليه هو
ما تم في بنغازي ا من اقتحام لبعض المقرات
ومحاوله ايقاف ظاهره الارهاب الموجوده في
المدينه ومع ذلك هناك امكانيه ان تكون لدى
السلطه الليبيه خيارات اخرى غير التنديد
نريد ان نعرف بعد الفاصل الى اي مدى
السلطات الليبيه قادره على التعامل مع هذه
الازمه واحتواء تداعياتها هذا ما سننظر
اليه بعد الفاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعا حاله
الاضطراب الامني في طرابلس وبنغازي
وخيارات الحكومه الليبيه في التعامل معها
سيد منصور الحصادي الان ماذا يجب على
السلطه ان تقوم به لاحتواء هذا الوضع
الخطير في
البلاد نعم سيد محمد قبل ان اجيب على هذا
السؤال اسمح لي في شيء لابد بين الساده
المشاهدين والشعب الليبي الغريب في الامر
ان السيد حفتر يتفق مع التكفيريين في عدم
الاحتراف بشرعيه الدوله وعدم الاحتراف
بالمؤتمر الوطني السيد حفتر يتهم المؤتمر
الوطني بانه مؤتمر غير شرعي ومنتهي
الصلاحيه بعض الفكر التكفيري في ليبيا
يتهم المؤتمر الوطني بانه المؤتمر الوثني
انا استغرب كيف يتفق هؤلاء في نفس الفكره
يعني كلاهما غير محترف بشرعيه المؤتمر
الوطني غير محترف بشرعيه 17 فبراير غير
محترف بمخرجات 17 فبراير
وبحكومة القادمه امامها تحدي حقيقي امامها
ملف معقد وهو الملف الامني عليها ان تهتم
بهذا الملف وان توقف كل الاغتيالات والسطو
والسرقه والجريمه وخاصه في مدينه الثوره
مدينه بني غازي وايضا في مدينه درن وفي
العجيلات وفي الجنوب الليبي هذه مسؤوليه
كبيره امام الحكومه القادمه لكن ما نراه
من السيد حفتر هو انقلاب على الشرعيه
انقلاب على المسار الديمقراطي في ليبيا
ايضا هو تعطيل الانتخابات البرلمانيه
القادمه وهذا هدف من الثوره المضاده الان
التي تشتغل في ليبيا نحن البعض ايضا سيد
حص البعض ايض سي ح نعم بس بعد اذنك البعض
يعتقد وهنا اسال الدكتور بعيره البعض
يعتقد بان ربما المتسبب في هذا الوضع هو
قانون العزل او ما يشعر
به ما تشعر به قيادات عسكريه من النظام
السابق او قاده سياسيون بانه تم استبعاده
هل تعتقد سيد بعير ان ربما قانون العزل
وتهميش هؤلاء كما يقولون ساهم في ظهور
ظهيره
حفتر لا اعتقد ذلك اولا قانون العزل
السياسي اثار ليست كثيره على المجتمع
الليبي
وصحيح ان صدوره كان غير واقعي باعتبار ان
اصبح يحاسب الناس على مواقعها ووظائفها
اللي كانت فيها في حين كان الاجدر
اي بالمؤتمر عند ما اصدر هذا القانون ان
يحاسب الناس على ما قدمت ضد الشعب الليبي
من ولغ في دم الشعب الليبي او تغول على
امواله او عذب الليبيين او ارتكب جرائم
هذا يجب ان يحاسب لكن اي شخص كان يعيل
اولاده ويعيش في في في ظل الدوله الليبيه
السابقه ايام القذافي لم تكن امامه خيارات
اخرى الا ان يعمل معها لكي يكسب قوت يومه
فالقانون اخطا في هذه الناحيه ولكن لا
اعتقد ان هو السبب وراء ظهور هؤلاء
الضباط بما قاموا به الان السبب الرئيسي
هو الانفلات الامني والدوله ولا كانها
سائله نعم وهل هل تعتقد هل تعتقد دكتور
بان هناك امكانيه ان تخرج الامور عن
السيطره بالكامل لان هناك حديث عن ربما
دور مصري او امكانيه لتدخل مصري هناك حديث
ايضا عن ان القوات الدوليه او الولايات
المتحده قد تعيد الكره و تدخل عسكريه
لانهاء بؤره توتر اصبحت مزعجه اقليميا هل
هذا وارد نعم نعم نعم هذ هذه المخاطر كلها
وارده الجزائر حشدت جنود على حدود ليبيا
تونس حشدت 5000 جندي على حدود ليبيا مصر
منزعجه كثيرا مما يجري في ليبيا القتل
اللي يجري المصريين في ليبيا مثل مثل
الليبيين الاسلحه التي تهرب الى مصر وما
الى ذلك يتهم ليبيا بها الفوضه الامنيه في
ليبيا تطال كل احد ولذلك العالم قلق على
ما يجري في ليبيا واعتقد الصيحه التي قام
بها هؤلاء الضباط ربما
للمحاوله بالابقاء على الوضع الليبي بعيدا
عن التدخل الدولي لو تدخل طرف خارجي سوف
تتعقد المشكله اكثر وليبيا قد تكون مهدده
بالانقسام في ظل هذه الاوضاع البائسه نعم
طلما من الافضل تجنب التدخل الدولي سيد
منصور الحصادي هل تعتقد بان الحل الان هو
في المسارعه ب اجراء الاستحقاقات المطلوبه
انتخابات
رئاسيه برلمانيه انهاء كل هذه الملفات حتى
ننهي موضوع الشرعيه وبالتالي تاتي سلطه
قادره على المسك بزمام الامور
بالكامل نعم هذا الانقلاب وهذه الثوره
المضاده تريد ان تعيق الوصول الى انتخاب
البرلمان القادم تريد اعاقه تسلم الحكومه
المنتخبه الان تريد اعاقه المفوضيه العليا
للانتخابات تريد اعاقه اقرار الميزانيه
العامه للدوله الليبيه هذه هذه من ضمن
مخطط الثوره المضاده الان نراها سواء كان
في الداخل او في من يساندها حتى من
الخارج العمل في هذه الحاله سيد حصادي ما
العمل في هذه
الحاله نعم ما العمل في هذه الحاله الحل
او العمل ان العمل واضح وصريح الحكومه
القادمه ووزير الداخليه القادم ووزير
الدفاع القادم عليهم ان يعملوا بجد من اجل
تامين ليبيا ووقف القتل والاغتيالات وخاصه
في مدينه بني غازي ومدينه درناه والعجيلات
و والجنوب الليبي لكن المسار الديمقراطي
لابد ان يسير العمليه السياسيه في ليبيا
لابد ان تسير لان حقيقه المستهدف الحقيقي
في ليبيا هي ثوره 17 فبراير ومخرجات ثوره
17 فبراير اللي هي العمليه السياسيه
والمسار الديمقراطي والتداول السلمي على
السلطه ولكن سيد حسادي كلما تاخر حسم
الامور من ناحيه الاستحقاقات الديمقراطيه
كلما ازداد الوضع صعوبه هل لديكم تخوفات
من ان امكانيه العوده امكانيه التدخل
الجوار او التدخل الدولي ربما خطر
حقيقي
سيد سيد محمد سيد محمد ليس هناك تاخر الان
قانون الانتخابات المفوضيه العليا
الانتخابات اعلنت والان فتحت باب التسجيل
للناخبين والمترشحين وستكون هناك انتخابات
في بحر ممكن شهر او شهرين او ثلاث شهور
ينتخب برلمان جديد لجنه 60 الان احييها من
هذا المنبر تعمل بجد واخلاص في برلمان
مدينه البيضاء الاستحقاقات تسير بطريقه
ديمقراطيه بطريقه صحيحه ولكن القفاز الذين
يريدون ان يقفزوا على ثوره 17 فبراير
الحقيقه هم من يريدوا افساد المشهد الليبي
ايضا سيد
محمي بعد اذنك معذره لنرى دكتور بعيره ما
اذا كان يرى في ان الامور تتقدم من حيث
الاستحقاقات الديمقراطيه مما ينهي هذه
الحاله
الحاليه والله شو نقول لك الشعب في بنغازي
بشكل عام فقد الثقه في سياسات المؤتمر وفي
مواقفه مؤتمر بطيء وعاجز وقائم على
الصراعات الداخليه والشعب لا يامل كثيرا
ان ياتيه الخير عن طريق هذا المؤتمر ولكن
هل ولكن هل يمكن ان ياتيه الخير عن طريق
تحركات فيها بعد مغامر ف بعد انقلابي فيها
بعد خروج المسار الس سيد محمد يا سيد محمد
لابد من القاء الحجر في الماء الراكد لكي
يتحرك يعني ليبيا اصبحت بركه ماء راكد
الان كل يوم تزيد فسادا ولذلك ربما مثل
هذه التحركات
صرخات في الواقع اللي من الذي يحول ان
تتحول هذه البركه الى مياه اسنه بالمره
بمثل هذه التحركات نعم نعم نعم هذا هو
الخوف انها تتحول ال مياه اسنه وقد لا
يمكن اصلاحها فيما بعد ما يجري في ليبيا
الان شيء غريب منطقه الشرق الليبي يعني
منسيه بالكامل لا احد يعني مطارده غريبه
في شوارع بنغازي وقتل يعني في وضح النهار
ولا كان الدوله موجوده ولا كان الامر
يهمها انتخابات اللي تحدث عنها ضيفك
الكريم زميلنا الفاضل صحيح انها الفكره
موجوده لكن لا احد يعرف الان متها
الانتخابات الانخابات ربما تجي بعد ست
شهور ولا بعد سنه لا احد يتحدث عنها الان
عباره عن تواريخ هليه ولكن ليس هناك اي
موعد
محدد الشعب الليبي وخاصه في الشرق يرى ان
المشكله في المؤتمر وجود المؤتمر استمرار
المؤتمر يؤدي الى تعقيد هذه المشكله
الحكومه الجديده ربما هناك توجهات شبابيه
فيها وربما فيها نوع من الامل لكن لا ادري
اذا كانت تستطيع ان تعمل شيء مع وجود
المؤتمر وانقساماتها وتسارعها الداخليه
المختلفه ام لا شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور
ابوو بكر بعيره استاذ علم الاداره في
جامعه بنغازي شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من من
طرابلس السيد منصور الحصادي عضو المؤتمر
الوطني العام الليبي بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام
نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر غدا باذن الله لقاء
جديد في امان
الله ه